[Music]
well hello there you're watching the
press preview a first look at what is on
the front pages time then to see what is
making the headlines with the delhi
mirrors political editor pippa crera and
the associate editor for politics at the
delhi telegraph christopher hope welcome
to both of you so to the front pages
then let us start with the telegraph the
biggest rail strike in britain in 30
years dominates most of the front pages
telegraph reporting that boris johnson
has rejected the rmt's demands for a pay
rise of at least seven percent and
dismissed suggestions by union bosses
that fares could pay for it
the daily mirror reports that millions
of britons are facing travel chaos as
railways grind to a halt flights are
cancelled and petrol prices keep on
rising as it says the transport
secretary refuses to do anything
union bosses are warning that rail
workers will strike for as long as it
takes that is on the front page of the
metro
the prime minister plans to allow firms
to bring in agency staff to relieve the
effect of the rail strikes that's
according to the guardian
britain runs into the buffers is the
headline for the times which says the
strikes will disrupt exams medical
treatment and those heading to the
glastonbury festival
the daily mail says the rmt union is
accused of punishing millions of
innocent people by pressing ahead with
the walkouts which will force towns and
cities into lockdown
the ft reports that industry leaders say
the walkouts will hit firms still
struggling to recover from the financial
impact of covet hardest
and away from the rail strikes the ai
leads with downey street asking
ministers to ease restrictions on city
bosses pay in a bid to show overseas
companies the benefits of brexit
and the daily star makes clear how it
feels about dominic rob being in charge
of the country while the prime minister
recovers from a minor operation
well a reminder that by scanning the qr
code you'll see on screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's newspapers uh while
you watch the program so let us go to
our guest then the daily mirrors
political editor peppa creera and the
associate editor for politics at the
delhi telegraph christopher hope welcome
to both of you so a minor operation
christopher for the prime minister uh
but he's back expected at cabinet on
tuesday um with words from him in the
newspapers uh what's he likely to say
about the the rail strikes which started
at midnight
well it's very clear that the government
uh the tory government led by boris
johnson see
see this whole battle as as uh almost
like into the minor strike in the 1980s
a massive wedge they can drive between
their core support tory support and
there will be a support for labor
because many labour policies have been
quite loathe to criticize um these the
strikers tomorrow so as we go back to
working from home for many people um
others can't get to exams it's a way of
trying to uh the government to try and
put the folks on back onto labor and ask
what they're doing to condemn these
strikes yeah it certainly feels like the
the wheels are falling off does it not
if you listen to the news today pippa um
the metro goes with that it's all going
a bit loco
mayhem for commuters as the rail strike
starts firm is crippling losses this
paper says as those talks fail you've
got the airline issue as well petrol
prices going up you know
it becomes etc etc eventually doesn't it
so so how do you i mean more broadly how
how do you see the state of of the uk
right now
well i think anna you're right in
describing it as chaotic it isn't of
course just the the real strikes coming
up it's transport across the board and
while the government as chris rightly
says is
has sort of identified this as a
potential wedge issue with people i
think it's underestimating the public of
course nobody wants disruption and
strikes have to go ahead nobody wants
children to miss their exams or people
struggle to get to work or businesses to
suffer or indeed music fans not to be
able to make it to glastonbury later
this week but
the i think the blame
um for this will very quickly
move from uh from railway striking
railway workers if if there is playing
there in the first place to the
government for overseeing this chaos not
just on the railways but but in other
areas of transport there's obviously
lots of disparate reasons for why
um why
for example petr prices are going up and
uh why this is baggage handling issues
that heathrow gathered they've council
more flights tonight
but ultimately the public will be
looking for somebody to come in and
actually do something and for grant
shops to turn around and point the
finger at labour and say well you know
they're not condemning it hard enough
they're not they're not you know they're
not getting involved it's like well
they're the opposition mate you know
it's time to the government to actually
um to step in and while the government
has said far the government said they'll
supply that they don't want it because
it's down to train operating companies i
think very quickly the public will turn
and uh and demand some sort of
leadership after all they are supposed
to be leading the country
go on christopher
well i'm not i'm not entirely sure
that's right i think we are we've got so
used to the government stepping in
um over two years into the kobig crisis
um the tories might say well why should
the government step in it's not really a
debate between the governments it's
between these uh these uh well operating
companies
and their unions at some point the
government
should say this isn't our fight yes i
know we own we as a government would own
the tracks the rail tracks we're not in
charge of this of this dispute it's a
battle between
unions and their employers and maybe the
government shouldn't step in because the
government will get little credit for
doing so
but well you know the argument is that
the government is effectively the pay
master for much of this uh you'd heard
mick lynch as well the rmt general
secretary saying that you know that the
fingerprints of of sunic and shaps are
all over this deal effectively blaming
government for not allowing a deal to to
take place so you know as as as somebody
who funds a lot of this and indeed
funded through covid which was the boast
of grant chaps today christopher you
know they they are a stakeholder aren't
they
they're certainly a stakeholder but i've
been talking to tories today who've been
saying to me why on earth should the
government be involved yes uh we give we
um we allow these network rail these
companies to run the the the services
but really it's up to them to work out
how much they pay their staff it
shouldn't be up to us and i wonder
whether this is a line which the
government will draw and say at some
point the government's got to retreat
from our everyday lives and get out the
way
so staying out of this um does not make
this not difficult if i can put it that
way for the government um the daily
telegraph quoting the comments released
to the media before cabinet on tuesday
from boris johnson two high demands on
pay will also make it incredibly
difficult to bring to an end the current
challenges facing families around the
world with rising cost of living and
boris johnson of course pippa the the
very man who sold the benefits of high
wages as part of the the brexit
dividends
and the other difficulties is um the
urging of other
sectors to follow
make lynch picture there in the
telegraph um urging
teachers nurses and doctors to follow
the lead of striking rail workers so
that that starts to get very difficult
doesn't it
well this is this is right the prime
minister of course has said that he
wants a high-wage economy and uh only a
month ago number 10
uh decried the bank of england governor
who suggested that there couldn't be
inflationary pay rises or there
shouldn't be inflationary price play
rises for um public and private sectors
um and then we have simon clark two
secretary of the treasury on the on the
morning round today
saying that people can't expect um
inflation repay rises i mean the reality
is is that inflation's looking like it's
approaching 11
and in this particular dispute um the
the real operating companies have agreed
to go up to three percent people right
across the board not just public sector
workers private sector workers as well
really struggling with cost of living
and many of them don't um don't
understand why
they aren't uh being offered a as they
would regard it a fairer settlement to
help them with directly with that cost
of living crisis the government's
position obviously is that um
that actually pay rises could
could end up making inflation even worse
even higher and that's why they don't
want to do it because of the they regard
as the sort of more structural economic
damage that that could inflict
but it isn't just the rmt the rmt are
kind of like you know the front line if
you like
of these strikes and it's really
interesting to see what the government's
approach is going to be because
ultimately if the r t and the rail
strikes are successful in terms of
getting a higher pay settlement then i
think you can see other unions following
suit many of these public sector workers
of course have experienced um
real terms pay cuts over the last decade
many of them are now seeing as as in the
private sector of course union members
are in the private sector as well um
really sort of but low below inflation
rises which will really not touch the
sides when it comes to dealing with the
rising cost of living
and you may well see other sectors that
have traditionally been on very low pay
nurses being a prime example but
teachers
and other nhs staff too
being validated in any you the education
union's planning on voting its members
and then unison as well which represents
many hundreds of thousands of nhs
workers um is also considered consider
strike action uh should it need to
involve a high pay
and this idea of allowing firms to bring
in agency staff this is the the guardian
that's picked up on this
a move that the paper says uh unions
decried as unworkable unsafe and
potentially breaking international law
and certainly the business secretary
tweeted didn't he repealing these 1970s
era restrictions will give businesses
the freedom to access skilled temporary
staff at short notice legislation is on
its way many people pointing out what
was the difference with pno bringing in
agency staff so i mean you know which
the government was very firmly against
we remember christopher
well i think that's a very very fair
comment um you know i think that this is
exactly what the government were against
bringing in all those new staff in piano
when they got when they sat the entire
workforce and brought in cheaper labor
who were who were
brought together to get the services
back i mean yes i think it's uh it's
fair comment i mean i think this is um
i'm sure this really helps this kind of
language where they're trying to get an
agreement between two sides and
employment dispute to talk about
bringing strike breakers
and the ft um talking about business
fears of the cost of all of this
um the cost and longevity of action i
guess as well because who knows how long
this goes on for and how many sectors it
permeates into pippa that's the the ft
yeah i mean this is the biggest strike
in real strikes in a generation and as
we've already discussed it could go into
other sectors and mickey lynch has made
it quite clear that he sees this as
being a sort of a long-term
dispute um they're obviously sort of
doubling down and settling in i think
we're likely to see more strikes beyond
um over the next few days tuesday
thursday and saturday potentially
reaching um out into the summer
and and as you said spreading spreading
to other sectors so um you know there's
got obviously to be a big impact of this
on on business beyond any uh potential
pay rises settlements that they have to
that they have to reach it's also
um obviously uh could impact things like
leisure and tourism and and uh theater
uh ft suggesting that could be a hit of
more than a billion pounds um so it's
you know it's not a happy situation uh
not just for the the real the real
operating companies but also uh business
uh and industry more generally i would
say that the the big gamble the uh
the government's taking on this is it's
a strike during the summer when many
commuters may be happier working from
home if they're in white-collar jobs and
lucky enough to be able to do that and
the hope is maybe that
the mid it can be mitigated that that
way and it could be a difficult they can
get through the summer and not that many
people will notice that the the chaos
court yeah indeed so there's lucky
enough to work from home
uh not necessarily the hospitality
detector or shops and uh you know very
many people who have to come to work so
uh divisive in in some respects i
suppose for for them but we'll keep a
close eye on that plenty more though
still to come including this on the
front of the telegraph uh lord guide
carry claims are ripe for an
investigation there's the suggestion
back with that in just a moment
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back you're watching the press
preview with me once again the daily
mirror is political editor pippa creera
and the associate editor for politics at
the daily telegraph christopher hope
welcome back to both of you pippa talk
us through the eye then
number 10 number 10 rather the paper
says plans to tear up the limits on city
bosses pay and remind us
was this rules that were brought in
after the financial crisis
yeah so it actually stems from us being
a member of the european union but after
this financial crash in 2008 there was a
plethora of regulations which were
brought in because of course one of the
feelings was that high city pay and big
bonuses encouraged financial workers to
take big risks some of which ended up
being uh major factors in in the
financial crash um and so regulation was
tightened up across the board this
wasn't unique to the eu and i don't
suppose it would have been uh you know
britain would have done it regardless of
whether it was a member or not however
it was tied to being a member of the
european union and as we know there is a
real drive a real push in government at
the moment championed by jacob bruce
mogg but there are others too to try and
show the benefits of brexit because of
course the economy is struggling a bit
we have seen very low growth potentially
going to tip into recession and while
there are many international factors
such as the war in ukraine and china and
supply chains this resulted for the
pandemic it's definitely the case that
the government's looking for some sort
of big significant benefits of having
left the european union um rather than
sort of you know um things which are
perhaps regarded as symbolic but less
significant like weights and measures
and
and so on so and what they're suggesting
is uh in this letter which is sent by
steve barkley his prime minister's chief
of staff but was a former brexit
secretary jerushak the chancellor has
been leaked to the eye and it suggested
reducing the burden on business to make
it britain to make london a more
attractive financial center
internationally to try and encourage
people to come here post-brexit and
things like um the cap on bonus pay
could be lifted um currently it's a cap
of 100 of your salary or um or indeed
some of the other limits that are put in
place okay in terms of how you paid and
so on so to interrupt you've got a
couple of a couple of other stores i
want to get to which both your papers
are going with actually front page of
the mirror
shameless pm tried to get carrie two
jobs and the front of the telegraph as
well
down the bottom there lord guyt
the outgoing ethics advisor believes
that allegations that boris johnson
attempted to appoint his future wife to
a senior government job could be ripe
for investigation christopher
yes i thought this is fascinating it
shows what a wasted uh resignation lord
geitz was last week when he could have
resigned over this story at the weekend
in the times that that uh that um
josh looked at hiring carriers as chief
of staff when they first got together i
mean i mean he's now indicating that he
he he would like a future person who may
or may not replace him we don't even
know whether that's going to happen yet
because the pian may have may not
replace him at all
should investigate it it just shows it's
an odd story this one it's um it was a
you probably covered it over the weekend
um but i think
there's lots of shock and horror about
it but i'm not sure
quite why you've got to hear a prime
minister who did look at trying to get
donor money in to help out with the
the home furnishings of decorating in
number 10. um how far removed from that
is it to try and give a job to um is his
other half in in government then it was
turned down by the people i mean i think
this is the kind of path of course many
people for boris johnson